welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's like
goku
when it comes to breaking down grogu and
though i have no idea what that means
i do have some ideas about the ins and
outs of his past
after the latest episode chapter 13
unveiled a lot about the child
and throughout this video we're going to
be going over it all and then giving our
fan theories on where things could be
going in the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't seen the latest episode yet
or play jedi fall in order then heads up
as we will be discussing certain things
if you've been enjoying our coverage so
far then please click the thumbs up
button
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into the breakdown
okay so no matter what yeah i think i
will forever call a child
baby yoda one because i'm a noob and two
because i have 10 tattoos of him on my
face but above all that
i think it's because the cute little
critter is one of the most memorable
characters in the entirety of star wars
history
and over the last year there's been a
ton of speculation about who he is
and where he comes from theories have
ranged from him being a clone of yoda
to a descendant of palpatine and that
was pretty stupid that one
i know we don't know exactly where he
came from we do at least have some
inkling about his early life
now it's long been known that grogu is
about 50 years old
and in the star wars timeline this would
place him as someone who was around just
before the clone wars
ahsoka confirms this in the latest
episode when connecting with his mind
and she says that he was a youngling who
was trained at the jedi temple on
coruscent
this is something that we've actually
seen firsthand and like most of the
children at the location
many masters oversaw his development and
education
now order 66 really threw a spanner in
the works
and many of the jedi were murdered but
the few who survived did what they could
to escape
and help those that they could we've
seen this across a lot of media such as
the clone wars and jedi fallen order
both of which showcase the downfall of
the republic through the eyes of the
characters that experienced it firsthand
what i love about fallen order is that
we really saw through the eyes of khal
kestis
how his master protected him when
everything was going to hell
and it seems like something very similar
happened to grosgu
as he was taken from the temple when
anakin was massacring younglings
what a guy anyway we currently don't
know who the identity of this mysterious
figure was
and we don't even know if it's a jedi or
not ahsoka doesn't mention one
but i think they've deliberately left
things ambiguous in order to make us
speculate
now the first person who sprung to mind
when i heard this story was actually
mace windu
fan theories aside even when i first saw
revenge of the sith back in the day
when i was a youngling myself younger
than the child
which i still suppose i am something
about him being flung out of the window
just didn't sit right with me a jedi
could easily get out of that fall
and if palpatine can survive being
thrown into the death star reactor as it
explodes
then anything is possible yes i know i
know he's a clone
now there are also other characters it
could be and even on a last video we
brought up how they'd been speculation
for a long time
that yaddle could have been the one to
save him i know she's dead but yeah this
is star wars and it really could be
anybody
but we know for definite that at the
very least it wasn't obi-wan or yoda
maybe it was a jar jar that was [ __ ]
terrible
anyway so what happened after that well
the child's memory goes dark
and ahsoka states that he became lost
and alone
when the child was first introduced a
lot of people were kind of confused over
the age
as if he was really 50 years old he
would be roughly a toddler but he seemed
a bit younger
it's likely because he's pretty much
been left on his own without much
interaction
or even training that he's pretty much
remained in this childlike statementally
and this is something that we've seen in
real life when children are not provided
with proper social interactions
so him having this almost regressed and
underdeveloped personality
does make a lot more sense with us
knowing that he was left on his own for
what could have been roughly 30 to 40
years
he was still likely sought after though
and last week we discovered that the
empire had actually been creating clones
and were trying to harvest the
midichlorians from grogu in order to
give them the ability to wield the force
we don't know whether these clones were
palpatine himself or snoke
but what we do know is that the hosts
weren't compatible with grogu
and they failed to really do anything at
least this sort of explains why snoke's
face is so messed up
because he's a failure now we do know
that moth gideon is still hunting grogu
and mando
but i actually think that there will be
something that ties into the overall
plot
and means that he leaves them alone
episode 5 or other chapter 13
ends with ahsoka telling mando to take
the child to taithon
and upon placing him atop a seeing stone
that he will be able to reach out to
another jedi
now if the jedi can sense him the sith
likely can too
and thus if a jedi travels to meet grogu
or tells him where to meet
the empire could be well aware of this i
actually think that moth will take this
jedi
whoever they may be and with them
potentially being a closer match to the
host
they will be able to allow palpatine to
live once more
so if mace is still out there who knows
maybe he's harvested and helps to create
the sith lord again
ahsoka could be used as well and well
someone at the very least has to
as palps of course comes back even if he
doesn't look as good
or rather as bad as usual well pershing
did say there would be issues mate so
no you can't have your money back now a
lot of people are speculating that the
jedi who grogo reaches out to
will be luke as we know roughly about
this time
he was in the midst of creating his own
academy
luke of course trained kylo ren but i
think the events of the show
are a bit too early for him to have
things in place for it
they would also need to get mark hamill
back for the series
dh him and it does seem like a lot of
extra work for something when they could
easily just put another jedi in his
place
without going through all that effort so
personally i don't think that it will be
luke and this is purely because i've had
time to digest the episode
and i think it's just a bit too much to
bring him in now it could indeed be ezra
and fans of rebels will know that ahsoka
is actually looking for him
in the same way that mando wasn't aware
bo katan was after maf gideon
he's also not aware that ahsoka's after
ezra so you know he could sort of be the
middle man that brings them all together
we really don't know at this point but i
just can't see you being luke
and instead i do think that we will get
an established jedi
but it may not be one of the big
a-listers that we're used to seeing
unless it is of course mace windu but i
digress
i would actually love to see cal back
and i think that would be an amazing way
to link the game universe with this
continuity
now they would have to age him up a bit
as the game was sort of around the same
time as the formation of the galactic
empire
the series so far has had several
characters from the clone wars era
and they didn't look that much older so
meh they can get away with it i think
and i'd be a very happy chappie
i just don't know who on earth they
could possibly get to play him though
i'm scratching my head maybe maybe ron
weasley anyway
there's a lot of info we've learned and
a lot that we still don't so yeah back
to square one on that one but
i'd of course love to hear your thoughts
and theories in the comments below so
make sure you drop them
and if you enjoyed the video yeah just
hit that thumbs up button right because
i'll bloody knock you out if you don't
so sorry about i shouldn't have said it
if you want something else to watch then
definitely check out our breakdown of
the latest episode of the show which
will be linked at the end
we go over all the easter eggs we could
find and give our theories on where
things could be going in the future
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the marvel phase two box set
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of november so make
sure you get involved
going to support the channel and get to
see contents early then please consider
clicking the join button below
you can also come check this on the
discord server linked in the description
or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you've been the best i mean
ball i'll see you next time
i take care a piece
you